it's hands down one of the greatest
accomplishments in sports history i i
mean
i'm not going to say it's the greatest
but i would say it's up there for sure
you know come down here to tampa uh come
to an organization that's ready to win
uh come come down here with the players
that
you know they're all fantastic players
great guys everyone overall i mean the
story is just unbelievable and uh it
definitely ranks up there as you know
one of my biggest accomplishments ever
sounded a lot like a guy
who also recently relocated to florida
good lord have a little humility gronk
um it's
let others praise your accomplishments
gronk it took a while for the control
room to get what i was saying there
anyway grog is now
gronk gronk is now uh tied with lynn
swann
for the most receiving yards in super
bowl history 364.
uh he's got a ways to go to catch jerry
rice probably not gonna catch jerry rice
at 589 but rice and gronk are the only
players with multiple
multi-touchdown
super bowl performances as well so hey
gronk had a gronk had a great game i i
don't know how i feel about what we just
witnessed from him after the game but i
know how i feel about what we witnessed
during the game it was pretty damn
impressive
i mean he's he's still a force of nature
that that's really the biggest thing you
know ability to run block awesome
pass blocking tight end awesome and then
you could see
still really good in the past game and
you know a still a giant human being
that you got to tackle and bring down to
the to the ground i mean it's phenomenal
really i love travis kelsey and
everything like this but rob gronkowski
is still in my opinion the greatest
tight end i've ever seen uh just from
everything he brings to a football team
well and uh you know he'll be back as
well and i can't help but wonder
was this like a long con by gronk to
spend the whole year
running at a lower gear than what you
actually have and then breaking out the
real speed in the super bowl is he
is is he like a sneaky genius and we're
not aware of what he was able to pull
off he's a football genius congratu
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports